this is Santa Lucia the only desert
island in Cape Verde off the West
African coast a local NGO called bias
Vera keeps an eye on the loggerhead sea
turtles that hatch here they're studying
the turtles and hopes of better
protecting them but this time they're
too late co-founder Tommy Melo and his
team find a turtles nest that was
attacked by a ghost crab last night only
the eggshells are left
[Music]
so contest vintage vintage fantasma
spray this happens a lot ghost crabs
prey on the nests that's why it's very
important to make hatcheries to protect
the nests but crabs are also essential
and denying them that source of protein
could also have negative effects
scientists haven't figured this out yet
Regina no Cecilia ghost crabs are one
problem but it's humans who are the
turtles worst enemy you see vol inch
duty stirring that includes touristic
developments built near the beach and
nesting areas with all their lights and
noise then there's global warming severe
storms and rising sea levels which also
harmed the beach and one of the main
threats and kate bird is the incidental
bycatch of sea turtles by foreign long
liners especially Asian and European
ships
[Music]
five different sea turtle species can be
found in these waters it's also one of
the world's largest nesting areas for
loggerheads Santa Lucia is a protected
Nature Reserve and we need a special
permit to visit it the Cape Verdean
authorities and bios Vera want to
preserve the region as a safe haven for
the turtles at 3am we head out to search
for loggerheads sea turtles mainly lay
their eggs at night a single nest can
contain more than 100 eggs sea turtles
are slow and awkward on land this is
where they're at their most vulnerable
it's a special moment loggerheads nest
only every two to three years it's
exhausting work once the eggs are safe
under the sand the environmentalists
measure the turtles and tag them with a
microchip which will provide them with
valuable data
folks imaging don't be it it helps us
understand how the turtles travel he's
fine and it gives a better idea of the
degree to which they're vulnerable and
how much they are under threat bokhiria
da da acid the nearby island of salvi
santa is inhabited making it harder to
monitor and protect the turtles their
meat and eggs are considered a
traditional delicacy local households
still consume them sometimes behind
closed doors what's sometimes when we're
walking on the street we can smell the
scent of cooked turtle meat despite all
the protection efforts that
unfortunately still happens on some
islands a pasar la bouche for hunting
and killing sea turtles is illegal here
but laws are not enough silvano rocky
who is responsible for Santa Lucia's
Nature Reserve says that local
authorities are raising awareness and
preparing even tougher legislation hey I
do you feel it's a difficult job because
there's been a culture of hunting
Turtles but we have seen some progress
in recent years the city than windows of
roses for example we get more anonymous
reports from people telling us about
illegal capture of sea turtles Susanoo
animas useless given that didn't happen
a few years ago boys Calhoun zones that
guys knock on tcu people who are caught
hunting sea turtles can be fined up to
80 thousand euros
[Music]
there's some promising signs back on
santa luzia since 2014 the biosphere
organization has found no evidence of
illegal turtle hunting on the desert
island it's been a success for Tommy
Melo and his team